they've done nothing
zeroed
out i feel that the people that are
immigrants
it's not really their fault
i feel it's the fault
of the president allowing them to come
to the united states and give them
freedom to travel anywhere they want to
well he opened the door by saying we
have an open door they felt that they
had been promised
by the president
that they will become the united states
citizens you can't do that when you have
people
you know there are thousands millions of
dollars spent for our borders and then
to say we have an open border that just
don't match not because i'm a democrat
or republican but it looks very poorly
when the situation is big and the way it
escalated and there are not a lot of
responses uh from the
administration also when they do address
it and they address
uh some things like videos on the border
patrol that
obviously
were not what they're saying right and
that they address that that is a problem
how the
border patrol or our officers are
handling it i think it lisas our taste
in the mouth of all the citizens whether
you're a republican or democrat we've
taken a long time to handle the
situation because it's been mounting bit
by bit it's not just a thing that
happened
like over the course of just one week
with living so close on the border we've
had to
uh install because they're crossed right
down our road we've had to install
security cameras in our yard we've had
to put up three additional lights
because they cross right over into the
yard i'm not against no press or
anything like that
but once they get an office
it's just like they do whatever they
want to do i think it was handled poorly
but you know when you come to think of
it and you get 10 12 000 people
together like that it's
it's hard to handle it anyway it was
kind of hard because there was so many
people
know i think they did a great job i know
the united states
is composed of immigrants
but to me in my opinion you know
enough is enough you know
yeah you know i welcome immigrants but
not to that point you know it's hard
being here as it is you know
and uh
i know i see i see their problems and i
try to feel for them
but we have our own problems
we need to take care of our own people
we need to take care of our poor people
we need to take care of the vets
and i mean even in acuna they've got
shelters there and a lot of the
hispanics that live there say the
haitians and the immigrants get treated
better than they do when they live there